it by making a phone call to Brandon say
the hero of the Monterey Park shooting
well I I want to call to see how you're
doing and thank you for taking such
incredible action and facing danger I
don't think you understand just how much
you've done for so many people and never
gonna even know you
but I want them to know more about you I
still process
you know what I did and what I
yes so comforting for me you are America
pal so what the president is of course
talking to Brandon say about is that
video that we saw that surveillance
video when the gunman burst into the
dance studio that he owned his family
owns and Brandon say wrestled that
weapon away from the perpetrator and so
the president calling him and telling
him that he's an American Hero is such a
wonderful thing